ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
ministre l'éducation nationale ce sera
une nouvelle question sur les épreuves
communes de contrôle continu du
baccalauréat qui ont commencé le 20
janvier et qui se déroule jusqu'à fin
février
ces dernières et ça a déjà été rappelées
suscite des manifestations et blocages
organisés par des élèves des professeurs
et des syndicats ce dimanche de février
cent soixante six annulations et reports
des preuves avaient été signalés
cinquante et une épreuve où tous les
élèves n'ont pas pu composer et 148
lycéens ou les épreuves ont été
sérieusement perturbé mon département la
haute savoie n'est pas épargné et des
épreuves ont été annulées notamment au
lycée berthollet efforts et annecy au
lycée lachenal argonnais et deux lycées
ont vu leur épreuve perturbée par les
manifestations telles que les lycées des
glières annemasse le lycée baudelaire
annecy ainsi que le lycée chez un
concert écluses nous sommes donc en
présence des preuves annuler ou reporter
le lycéen qui souhaitait ardemment passé
leurs épreuves et qui n'ont pas pu avoir
accès à la salle d'examen avant que
l'établissement ne soit bloqué ou encore
d'élèves ayant pu passer leurs épreuves
mais qui n'ont pas eu des conditions
d'examen optimale car les bloqueurs ont
parfois utilisé des fumigènes des
pétards et de la musique à haut niveau
sonore afin de perturber les épreuves
les élèves et leurs parents ne savent
pas quelles seront les modalités pour
les examens ayant été annulées ne savent
pas si le barème sera adapté pour les
épreuves et ont été perturbés ou si ces
derniers seront re passer ultérieurement
des élèves n'ayant pas pu passer leurs
épreuves se voit menacée par 1 0 et par
les rattrapages alors qu'ils ont
simplement eu la malchance de ne pas
réussir à rentrer dans leur
établissement avant le début de
déblocage et j'ai reçu de nombreuses
vidéos en attestant
cette situation est temps que ce gène
pour les élèves et leurs parents qui ne
connaissent pas les solutions qui seront
mises en place pour pallier à ces
perturbations et de nombreux témoignages
font état d'une dégradation de la santé
mentale des élèves qui sont dans
l'incompréhension totale est extrêmement
angoissés vis-à-vis de ces épreuves
sachant que ces questions sont largement
laissée à l'appréciation des chefs
d'établissement cela ne fait qu'ajouter
à l'incertitude des élèves
je vous demande donc monsieur min si
vous comptez donner des consignes
spécifiques aux chefs d'établissement
afin d'homogénéiser au mieux ces
épreuves au niveau national je vous
demande également si des mesures
spéciales seront prises seront mises en
place afin que les épreuves qui n'ont
pas encore eu lieu
puis c'est au déroulé le plus
sereinement possible merci